Well, so what if someone a Muslim like
this is a real example and she said that
um she feels peace when she recites the
verses and she feels like she she feels
like she talks to God directly when she
sure prays and recite the verses. Yeah.
So how do you counter that? Very easy.
That's purely subjective. And you have a
satanic realm in which Satan and evil
spirits will give you a false sense of
peace and joy in order to deceive you
from the true God. I'm going to give you
biblical verses to prove this. But
before I do it, I say, "Okay, Mormons
tell me they feel peace when they read
the Book of Mormon." And they even pray
to God for this burning sensation in
their bosom, which is the sign whether
Mormonism is true or not. And they get
that burning sensation in their bosom.
So, does that mean Mormonism is true?
Because they're telling me they feel
good. And they ask God because there is
a test. It's in their their sources that
says, "If you want to know this is true,
ask for a burning sensation in your
bosom." The burning in the bosom. And
many will say, "When we prayed, we felt
that burning sensation in the bosom."
And therefore, Mormonism is true. Would
you then say that they are on the true
path? Because to them, God the Father
was a man who became God. So, he has a
God over him. God the Father has sp uh
has spirit wives that he has sex with
and he gets them pregnant. Jesus and
Satan are some of his children and their
brothers. So does that mean Mormonism is
true? It contradicts Islam. She'll say,
"No." So then why do you assume just
because it makes you feel good that
somehow that means it's true. There are
people who do a lot of things that we
know are bad and destructive, but it
makes them feel good, right? Yeah. Well,
I I actually brought up an example with
Buddhists who are meditating and they
feel peace. And then and then she said
that, well, this is my private affair. I
feel peace. Therefore, I think it's
true. And I don't want to Should I give
up at that point? Yeah, you can't.
You're now forcing her to want to be a
Christian. No, leave her be. But now for
you, for your benefit, and the benefit
of everyone else, I'm going to show you
from scripture, from the Bible, because
it's God's word, that Satan is in the
business of deceiving people by giving
them a false sense of peace and joy and
fulfillment. But because it's false,
it's only temporary. It's inevitable
that that path won't be able to truly
satisfy them unless they've reached the
point of reprobation where they have
grieved the Holy Spirit to such an
extent that the Holy Spirit is now fed
up with them and will hand them over to
the desires of their heart. So let me
repeat this again. Yeah. Yeah. Please.
Let me I got to repeat cuz uh there's a
lot of meat here and I'm trusting the
spirit to guide me to speak clearly
because again I need the Holy Spirit to
make sure I interpret scriptures
correctly for the glory of Jesus. And I
mean that I don't just say that to say
that. Now should I hang up now or? No,
you can listen. If you want to hang up,
that's up to you. If you have no more
questions, that's up to you. Feel free.
You can stick around. But let me explain
how it works. Satan can only give you a
false sense of peace and joy and
fulfillment that cannot last because
it's false. It's not true. It's not
anchored in the God of truth, the
ultimate reality, the source of all true
peace and joy and fulfillment, God. Now,
with that said, however, if a person has
resisted the Holy Spirit and grieved the
Holy Spirit and has reached the point of
no return, then what happens is the Holy
Spirit then hands them over to the
desires of their heart because that's
now the judgment that's fallen upon them
because of their willful neglect or
oppression, suppression,
defiance of the work of the Holy Spirit
in their hearts to bring them to the
truth. Now, let me show you biblical
basis for what I said. Does
Satan give people a false sense of
peace, a false sense of fulfillment,
deceives them into thinking that they're
on the path of righteousness in order to
keep them away from the true path?
Absolutely. First of all, you'll find it
taught by the Apostle Paul in 2
Corinthians 11 as well as in Galatians
1. Now, let me show you what he says in
Galatians 1. Galatians chapter 1 8
to9. Galatians 1:es
8-9. Watch here. But though we or an
angel from heaven preach any other
gospel unto you than that which we have
preached unto you, let him be accursed.
As we said before, so say I now again,
if any man preach any other gospel unto
you than that ye have received, let him
be accur. So Paul is warning that even
if an angel shows up and teaches another
gospel, may that angel be condemned to
hell. So here the implication of what
Paul is saying is there are angels that
are fallen angels, evil spirits that
will masquerade as righteous angels and
will present a message of truth quote
unquote the good news of salvation quote
unquote to deceive you from the true
message of salvation the true gospel of
Jesus Christ. And then Paul makes this
explicit in 2 Corinthians 11:es 13- 15.
2 Corinthians 11 13- 15. For such are
false apostles. Paul is talking about
false apostles who claim to be true
apostles, deceitful
workers. They're workers of deceit who
deceive you into thinking they are true
spokespersons of Christ, transforming
themselves into the apostles of Christ.
And no marvel, for Satan himself is
transformed into an angel of light.
Satan himself is transformed into an
angel of
light. Therefore, it is no great thing
if his ministers also be transformed as
the ministers of righteousness whose end
shall be according to their work. So,
notice what Paul says.
One of the greatest tricks of Satan is
to appear as an angel of light, a
righteous angel, and empower his
ministers, his servants, to give the
appearance of being righteous, holy,
pious
servants full of peace and joy and
contentment in order to dup you into
wanting that peace and joy and
fulfillment and follow them on their
path of destruction. It's right there.
So why would we be surprised that a
Mormon prays God if the Book of Mormon
is true? Let me feel this burning in my
bosom and bam, he feels a burning in his
bosom. That's not because the true God
is hearing him. It's because Satan is
trying to create that sensation in his
bosom to convince him this is the true
path, the path of ultimate joy and
fulfillment and peace. Stay on this path
because the end of it is destruction and
that's what Satan wants. He's a
deceiver. He's a trickster. He's a liar.
He's a conniver. He'll appear in a form
that will delight your heart. He'll
appear the the way you want him to
appear in order to mislead you into this
path of destruction. Satan will be what
you want him to be if he can then hook
his claws into you and damn you to hell
because he doesn't care whether you
believe in him or not. He doesn't care
whether you're rel not whether you're
religious or not. He doesn't care if you
want to be religious, if you want to be
atheist. He doesn't care. What he cares
is that you do not discover the true
God, the true Christ, receive the true
spirit, and hear the true gospel. You
want to be a Buddhist? Sure. You want to
be a Jehovah Witness? Hey, you want to
be Mormon,
Muslim? Anything you want. I'll be
anything you want. I'll appear in any
form you want. I'll give you what you
want as long as you don't come to the
true Jesus.
That's that's the biblical message. Now,
with that said, let me show
you the danger in that. If someone whom
God has reached out to by the Holy
Spirit, the Holy Spirit raising people
to preach that person to give that
person convincing proofs that this is
the gospel of salvation, that Jesus is
the God man, your only hope of
salvation. But that person keeps
rejecting it and keeps rejecting it and
keeps fighting against it and keeps
suppressing it because he or she is
content with the way he or she is living
and don't want to be accountable to
Christ or follow this path, this
religion because it may cost them their
relationships. It may cost them their
jobs. It may cost them their enjoyment
because a lot of people don't want to
turn to Christ because they don't want
to give up and their immoral behavior.
Let's just put it out there. There are
people who know the gospel is true, who
know the Bible is true, who know Jesus
is Lord, but they don't want to submit
to the lordship of Christ because
they're enjoying their lifestyle.
They're enjoying having for marriage and
they don't want to give it up. They're
enjoying cheating the government or
cheating their employees or cheating you
name it because it's allowing them to
make the money they want to make to buy
the home that they want to buy and get
the cars that they want to want to
drive. So they'd rather do this and
indulge in their pleasure than submit to
Christ and carry their cross and deny
themselves.
And so what does God say to those people
who continue in this path of defiance
and disobedience? Second Thessalonians
chapter 2:es 9
to12. 2 Thessalonians chapter 2 9-12.
And the reason why I mention these
so-called Christians is because I know
many of them. I know people who tell you
Jesus son of God, the Bible is true. But
they refuse to submit to the lordship of
Christ because they can't give up on
their gambling. They can't give up on
their They can't give up getting drunk.
They can't give up of having premarital
sins or adulterous relationships. They
can't give up, won't give up because
they enjoy it too much and they can't
imagine living a life without these
sinful passions and pleasures though
they are temporary. I know people like
that
personally. So that's why I mentioned
it. It's not just Muslims who don't want
to accept the gospel. There are people
who claim to be Christian and know the
gospel truth and still don't want to
accept it. 2 Thessalonians 2:es 9 and
12. The danger with such an individual,
he or she may reach a point where God
then says enough. I've given you ample
proof, ample evidence to leave you with
no excuse to continue to reject the
gospel, but now you keep suppressing the
truth. You've reached the point of no
return and my spirit will have no more
dealings with you. 2 Thessalonians
2:9-12. What does it say about these
individuals? Pay attention to the
context of satanic deception. Again, a
satanic deceit foed through the
antichrist where the antichrist will be
empowered by Satan to do miracles, signs
and wonders to deceive those who perish.
Why? giving them what they want and they
perish and believe the lie of Satan
because they don't know it's Satan
working through the Antichrist. So why
do they perish? Let's read 2
Thessalonians 2:9-12. Even him whose
coming is after the working of Satan,
empowered by Satan, with all power and
signs and lying wonders, and with all
deceivleness of unrighteousness,
deceiving you into a path of
unrighteousness that you justify and try
to pass off as being something that is
right, something that's not wrong. Hey,
why is it a sin for me to have sex
before marriage with women? What's
what's wrong with that? It's two
consenting adults. Why should God care?
Why should that be a problem? Or why is
it a sin? I'm in love with this man and
I'm committed to him in a monogous
relationship. Why should that be a
problem? What's wrong with that? See the
deceivableness of unrighteousness?
Unrighteous behaviors that they justify
and try to pass off as nothing wrong,
nothing sinful with such actions, such
behaviors. What happens to them?
Deceivleness of unrighteousness in them
that perish. Why do they perish? Because
they receive not the love of the truth
that they might be saved. And for this
cause, this reason. Because they don't
love the truth. They don't want the
truth. Right? For this reason, for this
cause,
right? God shall send them a strong
delusion that they should believe a lie.
Now, why would God do that? Why would
God allow them to be deceived and
deluded to believe a lie? Here it is,
verse 12. that they all might be damned
who believe not the truth but had
pleasure in unrighteousness. There you
go sister. So there are people who are
happy and content in their lifestyle or
their religion because Satan will make
you happy and content for a short while
because he wants to keep you away from
the true God, the true Christ, the true
spirit and true gospel. Now the Holy
Spirit's work is to then convict you to
show you that this lifestyle isn't truly
fulfilling and cannot satisfy and the
end result is destruction. But if you
keep resisting the spirit and
suppressing the revelation of the spirit
then you reach a point in which the holy
spirit says okay let me hand you over to
your desires
and that's dangerous if you reach that
point.
[Music]